it was also the day that the then san
diego chargers hosted a playoff game
against the new york jets
and
we had a room right off the red carpet
it was in between our our shows we
didn't actually have to work during the
time of the game so i'm watching the
game with the biggest then san diego
charger fan that i knew in my life
about five yards away from the golden
globe red carpet drew barrymore rosario
dawson j lo everybody's walking the
carpet bradley cooper it's the pouring
rain
everyone stops what they're doing on the
carpet
because inside that hotel room where i
was watching the game a table was
flipped over
because the biggest then san diego
charger fan in the entire world was
watching his team lose a playoff game
to the new york jets and now that san
diego charger fan joins the show solemn
massachusetts do you remember tipping
over a table at the golden globes when
the bolts lost a home playoff game
oh my god dude
oh i hate you so much yes
i do i do remember as soon as you said
golden globes i was like you set me up
setting me up right now that was always
the thing on golden globe day was trying
to find the windows to watch the
football games
i remember uh not realizing how close we
were
and um the camera met we were behind the
cameraman
and everybody stopping and looking at us
and then the red carpet stopping but you
know
fandom what are you what are you gonna
do
don't pay attention he's just a fan of
phillip rivers don't pay any attention
over here um dilemma fresh off the plane
from japan a little jet lag still what
was it like to be a part of these
olympics
you know it was
it was it was different
you know i in my in my 20 some odd years
of covering big sports events nothing
ever quite felt like this if you go over
there with the excitement of like i'm
going to do another olympics you know i
got to do the winter olympics and sochi
in 2014
but then you get there and you're really
in it was it was a true olympic bubble
for especially for the first two weeks
you know you're limited strictly to your
venue and your hotel
but um i was really impressed
with with the setup with what nbc did
to uh to make it safe for us to work and
then the athletes you know it was the
the athletes were still able to find
what they needed uh to perform under
very muted circumstances like you'd walk
into a venue excited like okay i'm not
boxing today or i'm at weightlifting or
i'm at surfing and then it was just sort
of like
it was like an empty room you know
they're there to perform um but what you
get from like the the
the international fandom and that
collective energy was gone from every
room and that um it was it was
it was different it was strange um but i
did overall i enjoyed it
my dear friend and brother selema
masakayla joining the show right now a
huge olympics for action sports i love
seeing the skateboarding this year walk
me through what happened and how it's
going to impact the sport moving forward
you know it was massive for
skateboarding street
and for um
park to finally make their way into the
olympics i i don't think the ioc
are
they're not dummies they know where
where the youth are and more kids are
skateboarding than any other sport on
earth it's it's truly an international
sport
and you saw that in
in the field you saw that in in in the
metal count
and i think people were really blown
away by the camaraderie among
skateboarders even though that they were
competing against each other
representing
different countries no matter who won
there was this shared uh feeling amongst
all the skateboarders that skateboarding
won
um
and that was really cool to watch you
know especially to see women's
skateboarding um
in in street and park i i just thought
about all the
the little girls that were that were got
to be inspired by skye brown i had a
friend who sent me a video of his his
four-year-old daughter in her helmet and
pads and skateboard watching sky brown
um compete and win gold and he's like
all she talks about is wanting to be a
skateboarder now so i think it was it
was it was huge for skateboarding i
think in other countries that have been
slow
to embrace uh skateboarding and have
treated straight boarding in a way
that's criminal um you'll start to see
investment and skateboard skateparks
being built and you know different
countries realizing like oh we can send
athletes to the olympics uh in
skateboarding so
it was a huge shot in the arm uh for the
culture
and i was really really proud to watch
no well said dude and you're right
skateboard skateboarding has really gone
global in fact the new uh boston celtics
point guard dennis schruter big
skateboarder over there right brockman
guy's really good with an ollie and a
kickflip then a shooter so i'm on a
skateboard
[Laughter]
why are you trying to put your hand and
dinner shoot his bag like that ben he
he did a good enough job on his own
messing up his bag he doesn't need my
help
at all dude uh you've covered a lot of
big sporting events you got to cover a
world cup in south africa now in olympic
games done the x games for so many years
a lot of the fun stuff you get to cover
with red bull just the idea of these
world sporting events these gathering
places of culture and sports what's it
like for you to have a front row seat
man
it's it's crazy you know when when i
think about like
the fact that yeah i was there when tony
hawk did the 900 i was standing on on
the vert ramp or or travis pastrana's
uh double backflip but i was also in
houston
uh
as a sideline reporter
opposite michelle foia when yao ming and
shaq went against each other in their
first game and it was treated
like a like a championship game you know
um
to getting to be on on the side of
mountains for travis rice's
uh supernatural snowboarding event i i'm
i'm lucky you know i i trip out all the
time
that somehow another someone got
convinced
that my uh
my rabid enthusiasm as a fan for
wanting to see people perform at the
highest level
uh in any sport
translated to me being able to be a
storyteller so uh i'm i'm here for it
i'm i'm i just feel really really really
lucky to still be associated with it and
um yeah to be able to have that capped
off with another olympics
somebody pinch me bro
that's also not downplay you did uh kim
kardashian's first television interview
joined now by action sports host selema
masakayla
here on the rich eisen show but is that
true filling in for ritchie do you know
that about the big guy no is that true
if you're gonna call that out if you're
gonna call that out say what it was
i did the interview where kim kardashian
broke the story herself
that there was actually a sex tape
whoa
that that you know like give me give me
my credit bro i was it was history
making
iconic stuff television moments you've
touched a lot of them over the years so
you're the one to the dilemma so yes
you're the one we found the guy
yes i i'm i'm responsible for all of it
i mean i hope ryan seacrest cuts you a
check each month you know i s sadly
knowing ryan he does not i'm sal will be
the first it does um
let's uh let's let's continue talking
about uh you flipping tables for your
favorite teams uh you're a clippers fan
uh what's that been like the last couple
years
man
i mean i i think that
i'm i when it comes to team sports i'm
addicted to mediocrity
like i'm just i have a deep allergy to
to greatness
um it's it's some sort of karma karma
that i'm that i'm blessed with so
yeah i mean i
i was i was one of those people in the
um
the elton brand
uh key rich days you know i was there
almost every home game
um
thinking that we were a thing
and then realizing that we were just
we were really an exciting layup drill
squad
uh at best
but um you know being being a clipper
fan now
i i know what to expect i can get
excited and then i know that when the
playoffs come
that the exit is is nigh and out
and i'm okay with it
are you gonna be okay when you see me in
real life wearing a purple and gold
carmelo anthony jersey how's that gonna
stay with you
i'll be fine with it you know because
you're you're you're you're a
bandwagoner
get out of here i just unlike you with a
deep allergy to greatness i have an
affinity for it i seek it out and so i
celebrate greatness carmelo winning a
title in los angeles will you be at the
parade will you be at the laker parade
when mello wins the title
listen this this sequel of uncle drew
will be very entertaining
you've inspired me so much throughout my
career sal and our and our friendship
and uh brockman over here is being
inspired by you when you said deep
allergy to greatness he wrote that down
that might be his fantasy team name this
year yeah so one of our one of our bits
is whenever just something funny as a
phrase gets said by either rich or one
of us or one of our guests i just write
it down so i have like notebooks full of
those for potential fantasy names
that's that's awesome i think that's a
great fantasy team name you should run
with it and if you do win your league
i'll be expecting my ten percent
massive joining the show action sports
commentator musician be sure to check
out the alakazam album and i want you to
talk a little bit right now buddy about
your organization stoked that you helped
co-found it's an amazing group of guys
and what they're able to do taking kids
from
at-risk youth situations or tough homes
tough backgrounds taking them out to
experience the world through action
sports what's the latest with stoked
thank you my friend uh we are a
mentoring organization
celebrating our 15th year
based in new york chicago and los
angeles and we basically use the
principles of action sports
skateboarding snowboarding and surfing
to teach kids how to fall down and get
back up
um negotiate
new uh environments and surroundings and
in turn
use those principles to make decisions
for themselves and and really find out
the totality of who they can become
as uh as human beings we do
mentorship programs we do internship now
we teach kids to brand build and it's
been an incredible 15 years run
we just signed vans
as uh our uh title partner for the next
two years which is really exciting as
well as woodward camps giving uh our
kids uh scholarships to woodward camps
um in the summer and winter and it's
been fun man it's been fun to take
something that you know you know surfing
and snowboarding and skateboarding are
my passion i don't just talk about them
i live them um and it was it's just been
really great to be able to take this
thing that's given me so much
and
help kids
get an opportunity to find out what
they're really really capable of the
organization is stoked the man is salima
masakaela from hosting my birthday party
in vegas with a korean pop star named
boa to hosting the olympics you've come
so far big guy i'm so proud of you
oh ben lyons keeper of all of the
receipts
[Laughter]
i will see you on the golf course
tomorrow
now it's official it's happening i was
going to ask you if you're going to make
that two o'clock tee time i didn't i
don't believe it so i see you on the
team but it's happening i love it i'm in
i'm in i got i i'll i'm bringing 24
balls i leave if i leave with six it's a
good day dude i appreciate you i love
you thanks for making some time for us
welcome home
love you man take care thanks for having
me everybody
masakayla joining the show fresh from
the olympics gonna make the the tea time
tomorrow that's the big rubble that's
the new that's the breaking news well
really gonna show up i love it
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here